I've been doing drag for about three and
a half years something alright three or
four years at first I started doing it
as just for fun or a little hobby of
mine and somehow I became serious coming
out to my family wasn't as hard as it is
to other people because I kind of knew
they were gonna accept me but it was
just hard because I didn't want them to
feel like I was a failure and my father
I haven't told him so that they haven't
told them yet but I'm sure he knows I
feel like sometimes you don't really
have to actually tell the person that
you're gay it's just something that they
know and they're okay with and you could
see it through their actions or the way
they talk to you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
first generation with you know my dad is
from Jalisco and my mom is from he Cali
my drag character is more like dark and
mesmerizing and when I'm not doing that
my other side is my latina side where I
incorporate just music that I listen to
also with my outfits I love to
incorporate my culture and bring all
that in because I am proud of my culture
I think it's beautiful to be a Latino
the drag is just art for me it's just
our a way of self-expression because I
still think of myself as a man it
doesn't change just because I'm a drag
queen or I'm queer
[Music]
[Applause]
even though in my culture linner
perceive that's more strong more
confident being it's funny that I get in
drag because I feel like a woman it's
more confident and more powerful in the
Latin communities the man is the head of
the household but the woman is the one
who holds the balls in a way I feel like
she's stronger I saw that growing up
with my mother
like she'll do anything for her kids
[Music]
hearing stories of my brothers and
sisters in Latin America and other
countries being attacked and raped for
being who they are really makes me think
how fortunate I am to be born in the
United States it makes me think that if
my parents wouldn't have moved here I
don't think I'll be feeling comfortable
enough to be doing drag or stepping out
on the house with a wig on
[Music]
people here still like look at me and
take a second look when I they see me
walking by the difference is that it
doesn't matter to me here because
although something could happen to me I
just don't care
[Music]
that's why I just feel like when I hear
those stories it just makes me not take
anything for granted and be so thankful
for having been important here and the
struggles that my parents went through
to get me here and that's why part of me
still wants to incorporate my culture in
my drag so I'm so proud of it and it's
something that makes me truly happy to
put it out there and let everybody know
that I'm gonna let you know and I feel
unstoppable
[Music]
Oh
Oh